you began making movies at 3 years old I
I would say three years old yeah it was
when I first started making films so we
had like a VHS camcorder right and I was
so inspired by New Zealand's Funniest
Home Videos which was obviously the
version of the you know the Bob Saget
America's Funniest Home Videos
so I would actually write and perform in
these sketches that we would then submit
to New Zealand's Funniest Home Videos so
it might be like it's my birthday and I
would end up falling into the birthday
cake or we'd be playing cricket and I'd
get hit in the nuts with a tennis ball
and I was like directing my family my
dad was operating the camera and I'd be
like you know make sure you get this
angle and that kind of thing and my
sister my mom would would act in these
sketches so that was technically my
first directing and acting yeah what has
been the longest time you've ever taken
a break from filmmaking you know once I
got going with it I just haven't really
stopped yeah it's been pretty pretty
relentless I mean I got into it in my
mid-teens pretty hardcore
and I've been going ever since I've had
to reevaluate where I'm at in my career
along the way and changed parts but I've
never really stopped I read in your bio
that you suffered from burnout at one
point yeah for sure you know I mean what
happened was I made these two
documentaries they were one-hour
documentaries and each one of them took
four years and I kind of did that on my
own I hadn't gone to film school I had
an amazing producer named Jonathan green
who supported me and we got funding and
they did really well but I just got to a
point where I thought man I've gone as
far as I can without some help and that
was when I decided to go to film school
which was in my mid-20s because I just
felt it was time to get that expert
feedback it was time to really study and
hone my craft I'd already started to
find my voice but I just needed to work
on the technique a bit so that was kind
of how I got out of the the funk that I
was in you know because I was kind of
depressed coming off my second
documentary yeah I've heard that from
other people too because areas like this
let down like it's finished it's out
there
and then you don't know how it's going
to be received or also the excitement of
it is over as well and just money I mean
let's be honest it all comes down to
money and financing these films often it
is tough financially along the way we
all know you can make a lot of money in
the film industry but we also know it's
not really at the front end you know and
you're starting out you're not making a
lot of money so that's tough yeah you
know and for me my second film was
really challenging I had some legal
issues with it and I also documented
family members in my film it was a film
about New Zealand his obsession with
rugby okay so you might think well why
is your family in it well the reason is
I documented my relationship with my
father because I realized that that was
the key to why I loved this rugby team
from New Zealand the old blacks that was
it it was my relationship with him and I
had some unresolved issues around that
relationship so I decided to document
that in the film now my dad and I have
never been so close you know we're all
awesome now but it was tough at the time
because even though I was telling my
truth in the film that wasn't his truth
he didn't recognize the character that
was him that was in the documentary so
that was really tough because I went
into it with the best intentions you
know I'm gonna make this truthful
documentary I'm gonna tell my truth well
my truth isn't my subjects truth and I
kind of had a breakdown about God what
is a documentary can you make anything
that's really truthful you know I
realized how subjective it is even with
the best intentions and I think that was
why I was ready to smash that mold of
documentary making on this film use me
that I've just made because I just I
didn't feel that a pure documentary was
it kind of a form I even believed then
anymore to be completely honest with you
yeah yeah I've heard that dilemma from
other documentarians where sometimes a
film is never released just because the
quote-unquote subject doesn't want to be
seen in a certain light and even though
it's kind of this raw light they want to
have it to be a certain way or look a
certain way or whatever 100% and you
know what's that whole thing it's like
you shoot a hundred hours of footage
it's 3d it's in-person it's the real
thing its life and then you see a movie
and it's 2d and a hundred hours is
turned into one hour and you're lying
through omission you're lying just by
cutting things out or choosing to
emphasize certain things and you are
trying to craft it into an emotionally
satisfying story now of course you're
not trying to mislead people but there
is a sculpting of that material I mean
I'm still saying really obvious things
here but sometimes when the people
you've put trade in the film see that it
is a rude awakening sure sure yeah I've
definitely heard people that there's
just tons of footage and they can't do
anything with it yeah absolutely you
know and you try and communicate with
your subjects but it is still your
interpretation as the director and I
don't know how truthful is documentary
it's still it's still one person's point
of view even with the best intentions of
being honest it's still that direct
shaping reality into a story well I find
interesting is you had sort of the
opposite journey in that most people go
to film school whether they become jaded
or not and feel it was helpful or not
then they go on to work or do things in
the industry or maybe they don't but you
had the opposite so did being in class
with other people who were excited about
movies really ignite reignite the
passion it really did it really did when
I went to film school it it kind of sort
of jolted me back to life and kind of
got me out of the funk that I was in and
it was interesting because I studied
directing at the national film school in
Australia which is called afters
Australian film television radio school
and what was funny was um it also
reignited my love of acting because I
had wanted to act when I was a kid I
went to a performing arts high school in
Australia I was acting two hours a day
that was part of the syllabus and then
kind of moved away from that to focus on
directing but then I go to film school
and our teacher Samantha lang was taking
these acting classes and so we were up
acting for each other for a week and at
the end of it one of the directors said
to me you know I think maybe acting is
your calling and then these other
directors that I studied with started
casting me in their films so that was
like that was an amazing revelation for
me
and if that kind of got me back in love
with acting so yeah being in that
environment just was so inspiring on so
many levels
you